the Supreme Court on the final day of
its term has just issued two
long-expected rulings first the High
Court decided it cannot get involved in
a dispute over congressional district
maps that were challenged as being too
favorable to one political party and the
court ruled the Trump administration
needs to explain more fully why it wants
to add a question about citizenship to
the 2020 census until then it could not
be added Jan Crawford is outside the
Supreme Court she's been looking over
the document Jan what are the justices
saying in this sense is ruling well I
mean I think the bottom line in the
census case is that it's not over the
justices and a majority opinion by the
Chief Justice John Roberts joined by the
four liberal justices are saying they're
just not buying the explanation that the
Commerce Department gave for why it
needed to add that citizenship question
remember they said that the Justice
Department needed the citizenship
information so that they could properly
enforce the Voting Rights Act but the
court in its decision says look we're
not buying that I mean there's a lot of
evidence that you cooked up that
explanation after the fact after you
already decided that that question
should be in the census this does not
mean there won't be a citizenship
question in the census it just means the
Commerce Department is going to have to
do a better job explaining why they want
one in the first place the question
though is time the Census Bureau said it
needed an answer on this by the end of
this month
obviously that's only a few days away so
there's a question of whether or not
practically they can include it in the
census but remember the census is going
to be online this year for the first
time or 2020 for the first time so it's
unclear actually how much time they're
going to need but right now it's not
over they're going to need some more
information Jen on gerrymandering the
justices by a 5-4 vote decided
redistricting cannot be policed by a
federal court what does that mean again
a decision by the Chief Justice this
time with the conservatives saying that
this isn't a question for the federal
courts to get involved in when a state
state legislatures are drawing their
electoral electoral maps that if they're
doing it purely for political purposes
to preserve their own power the federal
courts shouldn't be getting involved in
that state courts can look at it state
legislators can come up with independent
commissions for redistricting but short
of something like race discrimination
there
it's not going to get involved in these
issues that they see as purely political
disputes a very stron dissent in this
case by the way by justice Elena Kagan
with the Liberals in which she
summarized from the bench calling it a
really a sad day for democracy very
interesting Jen thank you very much